[Musique]
on le choix que tu es pressé nounou
sacro jeter sans le raconter une belle
histoire je crois vous allez voir faut
que vous allez voir
des seins vitement gros nounours hop hop
hop hop hop hop oraux
au sens mais petit chicala t'apporter la
sittelle sabah filippi oui je vais vous
la raconter alors je me pose
là
où on le diouloulou
[Musique]
disait
dauphiné pour lui faire oublier ce
garnement de lapin blanc et pour lui
faire oublier son quart ne m'en de la
pablo son papa au mna philippines dans
un grand magasin
il acheta à sa petite-fille de
charmantes une belle robe blanche des
souliers blancs et des gants blancs avec
lesquels elle s'habille a aussitôt
philippines tracker 11 un appel marché l
avant scène avec ses deux petites
menottes en avant les pieds écartés
s'ils lépine tu vient des philippines
trotta derrière son papa ces deux
petites menottes en avant et les pieds
écartés comme à petit canard
dépêche-toi philippines l'un philippines
s'était arrêté
devant la charrette d'une marchande des
quatre saisons qui vendent un oui est
frêle 10 10 10 10 tibi
de la peuplent caché derrière la
charrette était en train de manger les
fraises attend
philippines s'élança mais le lapin blanc
se sauva bien vite et
philippine tomba au milieu des freins
la marchande des quatre saisons et est
en colère le pape a aussi philippines la
tête basse autre à la maison ces deux
petites menottes en avant et les pieds
écartés comme un petit canard
sa maman fut fort surprise en revoyant
sa petite fille et filippino ci fut
surprise en se regardant dans la glace
elle portait une magnifique robe blanche
de ravissants soulier et de jolies gant
blanc
imprimé de fraises en rouge
alors philippines toute contente et pour
faire plaisir à son gentil papa joies du
tambour
et voilà les enfants
cette fois l'histoire est finie et je
n'ai pas oublié la suite aujourd'hui
dit tu nous en rencontrons encore des
histoires de philippe guillard le bien
sûr qu'ils nous laissent les livres oui
je vous le donne
tenu sa fille
catherine bibliothèque allons les
enfants
[Musique]
bannis de nos vies tellement bonne nuit
le petit là j'ai pas la lune est
faite de boer
où
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors patron vous avez vu huy nounours
tu as raconté toute l'histoire bravo en
route bonne nuit les enfants embrasser
bien fort vos parents bon j'ai toujours
bien votre soupe et fait 2 pour eux
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]